but these words well no I am very
pleased to see you and congratulations from
nobel price is customary 6 very kind
from when you received the news of
nobel prize you said that this one
you assemble unreal yes yes I'm
is it more real now
wi2wi because little by little we yes to
At the beginning we have the impression that it is
someone else
what does it sound like so much
strange that and
and then little by little we realize that
it's because we're a bit like
a sleepwalker at the beginning we do not know
very well
then after we yes we notice above all
when when we are in Stockholm
but I think of you as a guardian of
lighthouse of memory you relight the past
to save people have forgotten the
uses at the exact addresses for yes yes
same but because what is not necessary
forget ben that is actually yes
when when we talk about memory all
that we think I'm turned to the
past and all that but in fact it's not
it's not quite that
say that as we live a period where the
time has gotten a little faster with all
the internets the social networks
all this we have we have tried the
memory becomes a plus a species of
him for actually in time it was
easier to have memory because
that things were much more
slow while now everything is the
time is very jerky so this is
normal that someone of my generation would
either focuses on memory for
try to
to catch up with bits and pieces of the past as
because the weather is becoming so
so jerky things
disappear very quickly there is the all the
world taps as and when then
finally wants dadd doc salma that
causes a desire for more memory
strong maybe that in the other
time actually about memories I
know that you gave a picture but
nobel yes I know like picture and
what did I know yes I gave
a photo of a French photographer who
is willy ronis it was a photos
he had taken
in black and white it was a child
is pretty charming that this is a
child who looks at a cat but then
it's a photo I had
often on my desk because actually
it was like children
to women with children of my time
finally he said that reminded me of my own
childhood because even three-quarters
I could have thought press that it was
me or a comrade finally these photos
like that of children's dance years
50 but at the same time to questions from
mysteries at the same time yes it's this
mysterious because it's black and
white but at the same time this child
can also look like children's
now except obviously the photo
is in black and white then it gives a
little more than 2 mister o
and what did he replace his crazy
photo then we will listen to nothing game but
I'm happy I'm happy that
it's because I liked it a lot
especially but I'm glad she
be stockton not what it is
cc is one of my favorite cities
so I'm happy because in addition
I have ties with Sweden
family all so I'm glad that
that this photo is like it's like
if I was a little less time together in
permanence but because the city of
Paris it was a constant protagonist
time how do I stick to you
now as you are here become
a little more modern is that yes because
that I have come several times to
stockholm because I have a little son
Swedish etc. Oddly it's a city
which inspires me almost as much as paris
because I was in other cities
i do not have to berlin where they come from and
where in other European cities but
gégé
I feel like something is
two individuals game
an impression I've ever had in
another city is like I had
lived a life before stockholm
is in general I had been in summer but
as
the age one is in winter and the like
night falls quickly
that's when I do not know
why did I feel like I
already lived in another life that makes me
a funny effect and I never had this
impression in another life is good
true thank you very much sir monette
modiano is once again
congratulations it's a good evening
thank you so much